The Joe Rogan experience to go see
this one championship event in Bangkok.
Wow. That guy, one of my
friends like pet. Damn, he's a,
he's a a stadium like champion and he's
fighting one championship again and it's
like, it's, it's just six seaman. Yeah.
I don't think people understand
how big it is in Asia either. Well,
there's a lot of American fans that are
just really, they're missing it. Yeah.
It's like Asia's version of the UFC.
It's gigantic. Bigger. Yeah. Yeah.
The numbers are insane. And they got
some fucking killers over there. Yes.
They got some legit killers.
Yeah.
That's like that Guy Nasty Ucan who
just knocked out a Eddie Alvarez. Yep.
I try to tiger dude.
That guy's legit. Yeah.
I remember to train with him at
all. No, I would like alongside him.
I didn't personally try with them,
but I remember one day we were doing a,
we were training and he was the
last one on the mat. And, uh,
our wrestling coach frank was like,
he's like,
he said something like 10 more sprawls
in like you beat Eddie Alvarez or
something and the guy's just grinded
like he's just digging himself into the
Maddie. It was, it was cool to watch
him prepare for that fight. But there's,
there's guys like that that's like,
yeah,
he trains there all the time and he beat
Eddie Alvarez. Like that's a big deal.
I think it's a big factor over there too,
that they don't cut weight.
I think that's a bad factor if you're
used to being the bigger fighter all the
time. Yup. And then all of
a sudden now you're not,
now no one's cutting any weight. I mean
they, they have some sort of a system.
Ben Asked her was explaining it to me.
I don't really remember how it works,
but there's some sort of a system
where they stop you from cutting. Yeah.
Like the check your hydrated
check your hydration levels,
yet you gotta be some other way to do
it. And he's the right, he's correct.
He's smart.
It's the right way to do it.
We should've done it a
long time ago in the UFC.
I really think that all the
way cut issues, all that
stuff, like ruining cards,
all that, it would all be eliminated,
right? Yes. Ruining cards.
And even more importantly,
I think causing fighters to fight
it less than their full potential.
How many fighters got hit when they
shouldn't have gotten hit because if they
were recovered completely,
if they didn't have to, uh,
not recover completely.
But if they,
they didn't have to recover from
a weight cut. I mean, who knows?
Maybe there's shots you ate because that
you wouldn't have eaten. Yeah. Right.
Especially if you are some guys
cutting a brutal amount of weight.
It's entirely possible that you could
get hit with something you wouldn't have.
You didn't have to cut weight
or author. Yeah. Right.
We got five more often and the training
would be a lot better too because we
wouldn't like a lot of fighters
spending the last three weeks,
four weeks of their fight or their
cap. China's weight lose weight. It's,
it's the whole way,
the approach of learning and building
strength and all that stuff that you could
do. So I don't know. I
think it'd be awesome.
The only argument forward is that the
guys are tough enough to do it and cut a
shitload of weight,
have this massive size advantage and
sometimes it allows them to win and they
think they should be able to do it because
they're tough enough to cut all that
weight. Yeah, I get it. I
mean it does. It's hard to do.
You have to be a strong person, but I
just don't think it's good for anybody.
I don't think it's good for the athletes.
I don't think it's good for the sport.
I don't think it's good for anybody.
It's just an old way.
It's just an old thing that people are
doing so they don't have to fight the
bigger people.
You know?
It's crazy because I have to answer that
question a lot for people who don't,
like some of my friends are just
like, oh, like they'll hit me up like,
hey am I can't talk this week.
Like I got to cut weight,
like it's not a good time. And
they're like, fuck, how do you,
how do you lose 20 pounds in a day
and why do you do that? You know?
I'm just like,
I don't know how to explain it.
It's just because that's what we
do, you know? There's not really,
it's just what I have to do.
When you see certain fighters get on
the scale though, like Conor Mcgregor,
when he made one 45 crazy,
looked like a,
like a Zombie man is walking
dead character. Yeah. I was like,
Holy Shit Man. He looks like the
ice king. Yeah. What's that? No,
the winter king is the, what do you
call them? The night tonight? Yeah.
The night king. He did look like the Nike,
but did you see him when he fought at,
uh, when he fought Nate? Nate at one sone.
Look Great. You look great. Right? Right.
There's a difference. Definitely.
Yeah. I mean there's, wow,
get the difference it saying,
oh my kids are happy right there.
He's just like, yeah, I just, yeah, I just
had a burger. I know what to sleep good.
And then what's the math and the
other one? He's like, yeah, dude,
he's on death's door right there.
Really? Only three months apart.
Four months apart. 2015 and
March, 2016 is that right? Yeah.
Wow. Wow. You know what's
crazy too? Sometimes wait,
cutting messes up the mind to cause
you see yourself so shredded, right.
At one point in your life. And then
like, I can get maybe like five pounds.
I'm like, ah, man, I'm out of shape.
Like I gotta get back in shape. Yeah.
You get accustomed to it.
Yeah.